sie sind zweimal geimpft dann pech
gehabt auch das könnte bald nämlich
nicht mehr erreichen um gemütlich essen
zu gehen denn heute ist corona gipfel
wieder mal und vermutlich auch wieder
mal mit neuen einschränkungen
bundeskanzler olaf scholz will nach bild
informationen das künftig in der
gastronomie die sogenannte zweig plus
regel gilt brisanter diskussionsstoff
für und das diskutieren wir jetzt mit
unserem bild expertenrat so kurz vor
diesem corona gipfel begrüßen wir hier
bei bild live den chef der kassen ärzte
andreas gassen den top virologen klaus
stöhr und professor stefan kooths der
für die konjunktur zuständig ist beim
institut für weltwirtschaft in kiel
schönen guten tag hinein der gassen
fangen wir mit ihnen einmal an das ist
ja sozusagen die booster pflicht durch
die hintertür die da jetzt eingeführt
wird heute mittag oder wenn in
restaurants und kneipen nicht mal mehr
die zweitimpfung dann ausreicht
ja ein grund es ist das so natürlich ist
es unstrittig wir wissen dass gerade bei
nikon gebutterte tatsächlich wohl den
die einzigen guten schutz haben das ist
natürlich für die restaurants schon eine
bittere pille und von daher muss man
sich das sicherlich überlegen und muss
auch schauen wie lange muss man und will
man sowas dann machen wenn ich das sich
ausstellt das omikron überwiegend nur
leichte verläufe macht dann sind solche
harten maßnahmen wahrscheinlich eher
übertrieben den sinn und zweck soll ja
sein die den anstieg zu bremsen ob das
gelingt wird man sehen das wäre
natürlich gut auf der anderen seite kann
ich verstehen dass viele jetzt völlig
verunsicherten mann ist voll geimpft und
kann trotzdem nicht ins restaurant gehen
also hier kommt es dann sicherlich auch
eine sehr sehr gute kommunikation an
damit das auch verstanden wird vor allem
kommt es ja auch bei vielen darauf an
wie sie ganz pragmatisch damit umgehen
können also bei mir ist es so ich habe
kinder die können doch nicht geimpft
werden und ein sohn der ist bereits
geimpft und dann versucht man das so ok
also restaurantbesuch mit kindern das
geht wahrscheinlich gar nicht mehr also
lasse ich es gleich denn es ist ja ein
gewisser aufwand herr professor kurz was
könnte das für die gastronomie bedeuten
wenn immer mehr menschen also auch
menschen die vielleicht die
voraussetzungen mitbringen ins
restaurant gehen zu dürfen dann gar
nicht mehr kommen weil sie eben kinder
zu hause haben und sie sagen na ja und
wie ich weiß das ist so kompliziert dass
es halt nicht das hat folgen für die
wirtschaft das ist in der tat für die
gastronomie dann praktisch so etwas wie
eine lok downlight wir sollten uns hier
vielleicht auch mal überlegen es gibt ja
nicht nur die 2g plus regelt die kann
man sich in zwei varianten vorstellen
das eine ist eben dass sie tatsächlich
einlasskontrollen haben und die
gastronomen sind dann dafür
verantwortlich dass auch tatsächlich nur
diejenigen im restaurant sind die die
entsprechenden auflagen erfüllen man
kann es aber auch so regeln wie es
beispielsweise bei der bahn ist oder im
öffentlichen nahverkehr
dass die einzelnen gäste dafür
verantwortlich sind dass sie diese
kriterien erfüllen und im falle dass sie
das nicht tun könnte man den
stichprobenweise eben auch entsprechende
sanktionen verhängen das würde auf jeden
fall dazu beitragen dass die belastung
für all diejenigen die die kriterien
erfüllen und das ist ja die große zahl
der gäste dass die nicht weiter
abgehalten werden von einem
restaurantbesuch zweig plus für
restaurants und kneipen soll also kommen
herr stöhr heute mittag beschlossen
werden auf dem corona gipfel von
bundesregierung und ministerpräsidenten
bedeutet so was wie die booster pflicht
durch die hintertür gerechtfertigt
aufgrund der zahlen aufgrund der
schwierigen komischen zahlen die wir
bisher haben erst
sagen kann man ja von zwei seiten
betrachten
man müsste jetzt mal belegen können
wieviel fälle man verhindert durch diese
regel oder zumindest schätzen gegangen
okay wir führen jetzt 104
restaurantbesuche werden dann wäre
anders verlaufen so viel inspektoren
werden wir verhindern und so viele
personen werden dann weniger in die
krankenhäuser kommen oder auf die
intensivstation da diese zahlen würden
ja helfen auch die rationalität und die
verhältnismäßigkeit zu demonstrieren die
gibt es leider nicht dann lassen sie
mich noch kurz eins sagen letztendlich
ist es ja so durch diese regeln möchte
man ja die krankheitslast reduzieren
aber wo ist denn die krankheit lasse die
ist ja nicht bei denjenigen die positiv
getestet werden oder die allem
thematisch erkranken und nicht bei
denjenigen ins krankenhaus kommen und da
sehen wir eine relativ stabile
entwicklung und glücklicherweise eben
auch nicht nur in deutschland sondern
durch gute zahlen unter hinterlegt aus
den anderen ländern da ist natürlich
durch die winterzeit immer noch eine
sehr hohe druck auf die krankenhäuser
aber auf der anderen seite sehen wir
dass die zunahme der fälle die unter
umständen durch dieses 2 plus um minimal
reduziert werden könnte nicht oder
abgekoppelt ist von dieser von der
krankheit platz auf den dingen den in
den in den krankenhäusern die halterin
heute heute für unverhältnismäßig vor
allen dingen weil nicht bewiesen werden
kann dass das so und so viele kranke
soviel schwerkranke tatsächlich
verhindert zweig plus für restaurants
und kneipen der verhältnismäßigkeit kann
man mit zahlen belegen aber die haben
wir alle nicht wir können eben nur
anderen beschlüsse machen ja ok es
stimmt bin ich ein eimer wasser ins meer
schüttelt dann ist das voller
mathematisch ist das richtig und wenn
ich 2 g + mache werde ich fälle
verhindern aber wieviel lohnt sich das
verhältnis medial das kann niemand
belegen und deswegen wäre es vielleicht
auch jetzt wichtig dass mal zu
beobachten vielleicht gibt es auch
regionen wo man anders das ja ein
anderes herangehen kann man vergleichen
vielleicht wissenschaftliche evidenz
generieren aber aus meinem blickwinkel
gibt eben keine bahn wieder sehr gut
hinterlegen könnten herr tochter gassen
wie groß muss dann überhaupt die angst
vor der fünften welle wand nennen ist ja
manche überhaupt sein und wie sehr kann
das impfen denn jetzt helfen wir sehen
eher die impfpflicht das dauert und
dauert und es ist wahnsinnig schwer das
überhaupt umzusetzen und jeder hat ein
großes fragezeichen in den augen wenn es
um die bürokratie geht und auch um die
regeln für alle bringt uns das überhaupt
da noch hin wo wir gerne sein würden
so sagen wir mal so für die mikrowelle
ist auch dass die impfung hat die messe
gesungen da gibt's jetzt individuell die
möglichkeit sich noch impfen zu lassen
aber eine impfpflicht ob sie nun kommt
oder nicht ändern an der hong kong bin
natürlich überhaupt gar nichts mehr wir
müssen jetzt schauen wie stark wird sie
wirklich wir kennen ja die länder die
die uns umgeben die zahlen aus diesen
ländern da haben wir vergleichsweise
geringe zahlen ob das jetzt daran nicht
dass wir weniger testen die engländer
testen vielmehr oder ob er tatsächlich
weniger zahlen das ist extrem schwierig
zu beurteilen es wird genau was er sagte
natürlich darauf ankommen was bleibt am
ende des tages ein krankheitslast übrig
da ist man im moment eher vorsichtig
dass es sicherlich auch klug und richtig
heißt aber in der logik auch wenn sich
tatsächlich immer weiter herausstellte
micon führt zwar zu viel infektionen
aber die krankheitslast nimmt immer
weiter ab da muss man natürlich diese
maßnahmen um so mehr auf
verhältnismäßigkeit überprüfen denn ich
sage mal wir müssen ja nun nicht im
insel machen für ist einmal eine
erkältungskrankheit wir haben immer noch
die die sorge das ist durch die hohe
zahl von omikron fällen natürlich in
einem gewissen prozentsatz auch zu
schweren verläufen kommt und wenn die
zahlen sehr sehr hoch sind dann haben
wir natürlich auch absolut gesehen viele
menschen die dann auch im krankenhaus
land und vielleicht sogar auf
intensivstationen wie viel das denn
wissen wir nicht das system tatsächlich
diese datenlücke und von daher glaube
ich muss man wenn man heute beschlüsse
fasst die engmaschig auf wirksamkeit
kontrollieren oder vielleicht auch
darauf hin ob man den anschluss dann
zurücknehmen kann wenn sich die sorge
nicht bestätigt im moment ist es sich
wie sein ein blindflug aber wir tasten
uns da sehr vorsichtig und leider im
ranzen teil auch noch recht unwissend
voran und im moment ist man natürlich
eher geneigt vorsichtig zu sein und
dafür halt auch nicht überziehen wenn
man so ist die menschen verliert
irgendwann
und diese vorsicht sie kann auch jetzt
schon konsequenzen haben es sehen wir ja
an den vorschlägen die die gastronomie
betreffen der professor kurz was gibt es
da konkret für auswirkungen wie
gefährlich kann amicom überhaupt den
wirtschaftlichen aufschwung werden
also den aufschwung wird omicron nicht
abwürgen sondern allenfalls noch weiter
in das jahr verzögern die einzig
positive botschaft für die gastronomen
ist sobald diese pandemie hinter uns
liegt werden die menschen auch wieder
die dienstleistungen in anspruch nehmen
wollen sie ihn von auszeiten von vor der
pandemie gewohnt sind das heißt das ist
in dem sinne kein game changer es kommt
jetzt darauf an dass auch wirtschaftlich
durchzuhalten wir haben ja schon öfter
kritisiert dass die staatlichen hilfen
die dafür ausgezahlt worden oder
ausgereicht werden nicht optimal
zugeschnitten sind
und wir müssen jetzt auch perspektivisch
in einer situation kommen wo wir lernen
mit dem bios zu leben die vorstellung
wir könnten dieses irgendwann mal
ausrotten das hat sich ja nun schon seit
langem erledigt und immer nur vom worst
case auszugehen ist auf dauer auch keine
kluge strategie sondern wir müssen jetzt
auch mal wieder in so etwas wie ein
normalbetrieb hineinkommen denn auch die
wirtschaftlichen akteure müssen ja
disponieren und immer nur den
schlechtesten fall vor augen zu haben
gerade auch durch die eher ermutigende
beispiele die wir aus dem ausland haben
das ist dann am ende des tages auch
keine rationale politik mehr klartext
von unserem bild expertenrat hier und
auch der expertenrat der bundesregierung
sagt ja jetzt zum zweiten mal schon ist
muss klar kommuniziert werden mit uns
allen mit den bürgern und bürgerinnen
wenn ich das jetzt sehe was hier für
quarantäne regeln hier heute auf dem
tisch lägen in dieser mpk
beschlussvorlage das ist total irre das
dauert minuten lang um das ihr
verwandten oder angehörigen zuhause zu
erklären es gibt für unterschiedliche
bevölkerungsgruppen wieder
unterschiedliche lösungen je nach
wieviel tagen man sich wieder raus
testen kann ob man im altenheim ist in
der kita obmann gm zweifach dreifach ist
für alle unterschiedliche regelung ist
dass der wurf sind das die neuen
quarantäne regeln herr stört die wir
brauchen in deutschland
erfolgt vorgelesen das in baden
württemberg in papier existierte die
krone regeln auf einen blick und das
papier hat wichtiger 4 seiten irgendwas
ich beschrieben oder es ist schon sehr
schwierig war durch befinden die man
muss jetzt sicherlich regeln anpassen
ich habe ein kleines echo bei mir auf
der oberfläche könnte das ausschalten
also was mir an dem papier auch
aufgefallen ist dass man eigentlich
nicht von milderen fällen spricht man
spricht man selten noch schwereren
verläufen man hat die kinder was die
milden verläufe wird es auch nicht
erwähnt ich weiß nicht absichtlich
gemacht hat normalerweise sind die
kinder ja immer ganz prominent in diesen
papieren erschienen und hier hätte man
eigentlich mal prominent sagen denn die
kinder sind genauso sogar noch stärker
und dieser von diesen milden verläufen
betroffen also das hätte da hinein
gepasst aber man sieht auch nicht
eigentlich aus dem blickwinkel dass man
diese realität eben der wenigen noch
weniger betroffen noch weniger darauf an
wie man die immer beweisen dass noch
weniger die anfangs punkte von
infektionen noch geringere verläufe dass
man das auch umsetzt in die
tagesgeschäfte denn letztendlich
verlangt man immer wieder dass die
kinder jetzt auch dreimal in der woche
oder noch öfter getestet werden was
schlimmer damit erreichen dass immer
wieder auch bei der frage der
verhältnismäßigkeit also das glaube ich
sollte man nicht anschauen und bei den
fahrern ohne regeln ist es wichtig dass
man die realität ins auge gefasst sind
in afrika hat man ja die querelen nicht
deswegen gestoppt weil man ja irgendwas
besonders machen würde sondern hat
gesehen das virus zirkuliert bei in der
population es kann die kontakte die
kontakt beschränkung können die
zirkulation des virus nur noch minimal
beschränken man muss sich also jetzt
damit
machen wie man die krankheit last
reduziert also die virus zirkulation
kann man nicht mehr reduzieren deswegen
ist eigentlich quarantäne langsam auch
zu überlegen wie man sich dort aussteigt
und was sind die parameter waren wir mit
quarantäne und kontakt beschränkungen
aufführen die kann man schon mal
aufschreiben auch wenn das jetzt noch
nicht noch zu früh wäre weil ja viele
menschen gehen und die booster impfung
ist nicht ehrlich auch jetzt ein sehr
wichtiger punkt der
angegangen werden muss aber ich finde
hier hätte man auch bei dem papier ein
bisschen positiver weise reagieren
können auch allen dingen mit
entsprechenden maßnahmen sagt klaus
vielen herzlichen dank unserem gesamten
der bild expertenrat heute am großen tag
des corona gipfels und 13 uhr geht's los
aller ergebnisse auch all das was in den
besprechungen nach draußen was zu uns
dringt werden wir natürlich hier
verkünden sie darüber informieren vielen
herzlichen dank ihnen soweit für das
gespräch